[Music]
we are getting a much closer look this
morning at one of the major ripple
effects of the new anti-abortion laws in
texas to obtain an abortion listen to
this patients are crossing state lines
and traveling greater distances for care
if
if they have the resources including one
woman that janet shamley and spoke with
in colorado
okay are you currently pregnant this is
a rare look inside a clinic performing
abortions
i am booked for the rest of this week
comprehensive women's health has been
inundated with calls from women who live
in texas but want to come here
even though it's located hundreds of
miles from texas in denver colorado
why are they coming to colorado dr
rebecca cohen is the clinic director
many of the clinics in surrounding
states face restrictions on the number
of appointments that someone needs on
waiting periods on other barriers to
care the appointments are back to back
all day
ten o'clock km is a six week surgical
with p.o sedation no records
10 30 jt
since the texas band as many as 40
percent of patients here are from the
lone star state including a woman who
traveled more than 1600 miles round trip
for an abortion
we've concealed her identity
when you realized you could not get the
procedure in texas what did you think i
cried i cried all the way from when they
told me through the counselor session i
was honestly i didn't know what i was
going to do the 34-year-old mother of
three says she used money saved for a
family vacation for the airfare and
other expenses she wasn't paid for the
day she took off work so you just
finished the procedure here but you're
not finished so after a procedure you're
supposed to take it easy i'm not going
to get that option because i'm going to
have to walk through the airport and
everything else to get back home she
tells me she was past six weeks when her
pregnancy was confirmed in texas making
her ineligible for the procedure there
colorado clinics have no waiting period
why many women are traveling here like
the mom we talked to she couldn't be
away from her children overnight
okay how old is she and it's not just
colorado seeing an increase
even with a 24 hour waiting period this
shreveport louisiana clinic is booked at
least three weeks out they used to be
able to see patients within a few days
what are they asking what are they
telling you
they're literally begging to get in and
be seen as quickly as possible for women
who can't afford out-of-state travel
options are limited so i was lucky
enough that i had already had money put
back but there are women out there who
don't and i'm not sure exactly what
they're going to do
we watched as the phones rang non-stop
here in shreveport staffers telling me
they've always had some patience from
texas because they are close to the
state line the difference now the
distances that women are traveling some
women coming here are doing so from
mcallen texas now that is close to the
mexico border a nine-hour drive
nate
yeah regardless of where you may stand
on this issue voices like this um they
give a face to what's going on thank you
so much janet